♪♪
Good morning, my dear.
Action!
♪♪
So Tehran is an espionage
thriller about a young Mossad
agent
Niv:
sent to Tehran for a special
mission.
♪♪
Niv:
It's the first time that you see
on screen a completely different
Niv:
humane angle of the
Iranian / Israeli conflict.
It shows the messy grey area of
life.
♪♪
Glenn Close:
There's no black and white.
♪♪
And I think that's truthful.
From the first season,
Dana Eden:
Tamar Rabinyan...
...infiltrates Tehran.
The mission basically failed.
♪♪
In the second season, we are two
months later.
Niv:
Tamar and Milad, they're stuck.
Hiding from the Mossad and the
Sepah.
Faraz has been chasing her for a
long time.
Sherbin:
They are seemingly determined to
get out of Iran...
...but you know, in this show,
plans don't work out.
♪♪
I can't leave yet.
Her war against the regime
becomes really, really personal.
I know how to get to Assid
Mohammadi and I want to take him
out.
How?
Tamar:
His son, Peiyman.
♪♪
Season two deals a lot with the
hypocrisy and double standard.
♪♪
In Tehran you have very wealthy
people connected to the regime.
Dana Eden:
Tamar is in a more
dangerous position.
Niv Sultan:
She needs to get deep
undercover.
Niv Sultan:
Near the most important people
in Tehran
Niv Sultan:
and the most dangerous people.
She has a lot to lose.
Glenn Close:
Each person has their own story.
You're not always sure exactly
who's antagonist and who's
protagonist.
Daniel Sirkin:
Faraz is the most feared man in
the Iranian Intelligence.
Because of his work,
Shila Ommi:
his wife was kidnapped.
Shaun Toub:
And he was shot.
So Naahid is dealing with PTSD.
♪♪
Shaun Toub:
And Faraz is a different man
now.
Sort of a has-been.
He wants to be back where he
was.
♪♪
Glenn Close is joining us this
season.
She's what you would expect from
Glenn Close and much more.
Glenn Close:
Marjan is a very high profile
psychiatrist
and deep cover Mossad agent.
♪♪
Glenn Close:
I come as a therapist for
Naahid,
Glenn Close;
to get to Faraz.
Glenn Close:
That's one of those very
conflicted moments
Glenn Close:
as a psychiatrist verse a Mossad
agent.
In our series we offer a new
perspective on Tehran.
Dana Eden:
We really wanted to see the
people in Iran, how do they live, what do they think.
You really feel like you're deep
in another culture.
♪♪
Niv Sultan:
It's not only about the
action.
There's so many layers.
We can trust him?
Yes, but can he handle it?
It's high stakes, but there's a
lot of emotion in it.
This season is much more
exciting, dangerous,
heartbreaking.
Glenn Close:
It's really tense and fast
moving,
and just great entertainment.
♪♪
It's so much fun.
(Explosion)
♪♪